okay so he's got he's got it
lodged into his shoulder but there's
it's really quite easy to
to move it here okay and then and then
here you have the
the juji noggin and it's like ikyo so in
just work the mechanics won't pop in
okay let's go he goes
it's not this is not uncommon a person
isn't paying attention to the corner
and his weapon is out okay so he's gonna
he goes you're gonna see the weapon
and you're gonna do the 10 comedy
there you go you see it hold it
okay so we're over here
and we're just to work that like he's
walking
boom up
this is your monotone
from
up not around
towards you
all right
[Music]
inside his move
inside his movement inside his movement
so the same thing here i'm not going to
go like this this is
outside oh that's outside his movement
i have to be inside the circle inside
the circle
up it goes
so bone inside
[Music]
inside this circle in here inside that
circle
not out here
inside the circle i'm generating inside
the circle
up it goes strip it off the shoulder and
you go
inside the circle up strip
attack
don't smell eco because he has three
points in context so don't go
don't don't smell that thing right keep
it in your pocket
you don't have that there you're gonna
have to strip it off that third point of
contact
a womb inside the circle up strip
it off then you have
inside the circle up strip
in
inside the circle up strip in
when you come in make sure you're not
lasering yourself again
inside
[Music]
okay so or
the kosa grab on what i did okay
ego doesn't go and push him here
you feel his energy is going this way
and so i let it go i let it keep going
around
you see that hand keeps going around
that's what stops
me from lasering myself
[Music]
this has to go this energy has to go off
of me i can't just shove him away
this energy is going to go right around
me
around me and that stops me from being
lazy
make some mistakes strip
in
inside the circle script
don't get lasered try it again